tenemos las siguientes fracciones un
cuarto y cinco sextos y queremos
reescribir las de manera que tengan el
mismo denominador y numeradores enteros
qué números podríamos usar para el
denominador de modo que éstas son
nuestras fracciones un cuarto y cinco
sextos y queremos reescribir las para
tener nuevos denominadores actualmente
tenemos un 4 y un 6 como denominador y
podríamos elegir cualquier otro tal vez
un 5 podríamos cambiar estos dos para
tener un 5 como denominador la respuesta
es no tenemos que elegir un múltiplo de
4 y de 6 un múltiplo un número que sea
el resultado de multiplicar 4 en este
caso por algún otro número así que por
ejemplo algunos múltiplos de 4 serían 4
por 1 es igual a 4 4 por 2 es igual a 8
4 por 3 es igual a 12 y así
sucesivamente
estos son múltiplos de 4 detengámonos
aquí y veamos por qué tenemos que elegir
un múltiplo de 4 y de 6
porque no podemos elegir cualquier
número sino que tenemos que elegir un
múltiplo de nuestros denominadores la
fracción de la que estamos hablando es
un cuarto podríamos revisar cualquiera
de las dos pero veamos un cuarto aquí
tenemos una imagen que nos muestra
cuartos y para mostrar un cuarto sombra
hemos una de estas cuatro piezas del
mismo tamaño
tal vez queremos cambiar esto y tener
dos como numerador entonces para tener
un 2 como numerador vamos a tener que
dividir este cuarto en dos partes ahora
tenemos dos piezas sombreadas así que
podemos decir que estas son dos de 1 2 3
4 ó 5 piezas no son dos quintos porque
no son piezas del mismo tamaño si
dividimos este cuarto a la mitad tenemos
que dividir todos por la mitad y lo que
estamos haciendo es duplicando la
cantidad de piezas así que ahora estas
son dos piezas estas son dos y estas son
dos porque necesitamos piezas de igual
tamaño de modo que ahora tenemos dos
piezas de 1
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
piezas de igual tamaño dos octavos y
podemos ver que 8 es múltiplo de 4 por
que multiplicamos por 2 multiplicamos
cada una de nuestras piezas por 2
también multiplicamos nuestro numerador
por 2 porque eso también se duplicó la
cantidad de piezas sombreadas se duplicó
cuando la cantidad total de piezas se
duplicó ahora no solo tenemos que hacer
esto con 2 podríamos obtener cualquier
múltiplo de 4 por ejemplo podemos hacer
uno más aquí nuevamente sombre amos un
cuarto una de las cuatro piezas y esta
vez queremos dividirla en tres piezas de
igual tamaño así que para tener un nuevo
numerador de 3 estos deben ser del mismo
tamaño aquí tenemos un 3 como numerador
pero todavía no podemos poner nuestro
denominador porque no tenemos piezas del
mismo tamaño de modo que para obtener
piezas del mismo tamaño necesitaremos
dividir cada uno de estos cuartos en 3
así que estamos triplicando la cantidad
de piezas ahora tenemos tres piezas
sombreadas de un total de 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 piezas y podría haberlo
resuelto sin contar porque sabía que
habíamos triplicado el número de piezas
esta vez multiplicamos nuestro
denominador original por 3
triplicamos y también multiplicamos
nuestro numerador por 3 así que estos
son múltiplos 8 12 etcétera y estos son
los denominadores que podemos elegir
multiplicamos nuestro denominador por
algún número y obtenemos la cantidad
total de piezas esto es muy claro un
cuarto dos octavos 312 abós todos
representan la misma cantidad la
cantidad original era un cuarto y aquí
tenemos los octavos 312 abós todos son
equivalentes todos representan la misma
cantidad solo son formas diferentes de
escribir el mismo número regresemos a
nuestra pregunta original
denominadores podemos usar para cuartos
y sextos sabemos que necesitamos usar
múltiplos así que revisemos los
múltiplos para 4 ya hemos revisado
algunos el primer múltiplo de 4 es 4 por
1 que es igual a 4 el segundo múltiplo
de 4 es 8 4 por 2 es igual a 8 podríamos
dividir nuestros cuartos a la mitad y
obtener octavos o podríamos decir que 4
por 3 es igual a 12 lo cual mostramos
cuando dividimos nuestros cuartos en
tres partes iguales o podríamos
multiplicar cuatro por cuatro que es 16
4 por 5 es 20 4 por 6 es 24 y así
sucesivamente la razón por la que nos
detenemos en 24 es porque al revisar
nuestras opciones de respuesta podemos
ver que 24 es el número más grande
disponible así que no necesitamos
escribir más
hay muchos más múltiplos de 4 pero no
necesitamos enumerar los todos porque el
mayor número que vamos a considerar es
24 hagamos lo mismo para los sextos
podríamos dejarlo en sextos 6 por 1 y
dejar 6 piezas o podríamos duplicar
nuestros sextos 6 por 2 es igual a 12 si
duplicamos las piezas tendríamos 12
piezas podríamos tener 6 por 3 que es
igual a 18 o 6 por 4 podríamos dividir
cada uno de nuestros sextos en cuatro
partes y tendríamos 6 por 4 que es igual
a 24 y nuevamente me detendré en 24 ya
que es el número más grande que vamos a
considerar de modo que según nuestras
opciones de respuesta de números
podríamos usar para el denominador
podríamos usar 8 revisemos estas listas
8 es múltiplo de 4 por lo que
definitivamente podríamos dividir
cuartos en octavos pero 8 no es múltiplo
de 6 no podemos dividir sextos en
octavos
de modo que 8 no funcionará como
para ambas fracciones que tal 12 12 es
un múltiplo de 4 ya lo dibujamos y 12 es
múltiplo de 6 podríamos dividir nuestros
sextos en dos partes iguales cada uno y
tendríamos doceavos entonces 12 funciona
12 es un denominador común para cuartos
y sextos 18 18 está aquí en los sextos
podríamos dividir sextos en 18 ambos
porque 18 es un múltiplo de 6 pero no es
un múltiplo de 4 así que podemos
descartar 18 18 no es un denominador
común y 24 como recordarán fue el último
número que escribimos en las dos listas
entonces 24 si podría ser un denominador
para cuartos y sextos de modo que
podríamos usar 12 o 24 y hay muchos más
números que podríamos usar también como
denominadores comunes pero de estas
opciones podríamos usar 12 o 24 como
denominador común para cuartos y sextos
un dato más
le gusta usar el número más pequeño el
mínimo común denominador que en este
caso es 12 y tiene mucho sentido porque
es más fácil hacer cálculos con números
más pequeños pero no tienes que usar el
más pequeño puedes usar 12 o 24 o muchas
otras opciones de nuevo probablemente es
más fácil trabajar con el 12 simplemente
porque es un número más pequeño pero
para responder esta pregunta 12 y 24 son
denominadores comunes que podemos usar
para cuartos y sextos